hello folks welcome to rational science
directly from Frankfurt Germany
it's about nine o'clock
over here nine o'clock at night here in
Germany
anyways last week I went to the
Oktoberfest in Munich Munich and uh
great party we had a great time with my
wife over there uh we always meet
friends that invite us uh every year we
we haven't gone in a couple years
because of the covid but this time we
had a great fun some of these people
we've known for 40 years now so we get
together every now and then just uh to
find out how things are do are going
anyway from there I went to Salzburg
Austria
and I went to visit uh another great
friend of mine and
um she's a businesswoman great lady and
she's the patron saint
of dissidents
she does help a lot of dissidents out
there you know people who fight against
the establishment she's very strongly
against all the stuff that's coming out
of the establishment and so she's helped
a lot of people and she was the one who
um organized the what was the second
rational physics conference in
2014. some of you who were there you
probably remember this see if I could
show this okay and I presented my rogue
model over there
okay and uh other people were able to
present their uh opposition especially
to The Establishment okay so uh you know
she's the one who organizes again she's
a great uh lady great businesswoman
she's done very well in her life uh uh
with uh especially uh helping dissidents
and um you know we should all keep her
in mind all of you who know her and so I
went there to baptize her okay I went
there to baptize her and I baptized her
as Santa Monica okay she's Santa Monica
the patron saint of dissidence okay
grand old lady I hope uh all of you who
know her know who I'm talking about okay
and uh yeah we owe a lot to her so uh
just keep her in mind
um uh you know for different things we
might even have uh another
um
conference maybe in Austria Salzburg
okay great City also and I think she had
two of them over there
anyways
um after that I came back and I came
back with a cold so uh I'm a little
congested took an aspirin a little while
ago I hope uh I don't sneeze or cough
too much okay so let's see how it goes
anyways today I'm going to be talking
about Flatlanders okay who are the
Flatlanders well there's uh several
sects of this religion you have the flat
earthers you have the flat universes and
a lot of other uh flat earther flatter
Flatlanders out there people who uh
propose or who deal with FL the world of
flat
and one question I have with that is
that they never defined the word flat
they don't know what flat is okay but
that's not the reason uh all these
people are Flatlanders they're
Flatlanders because they use the wrong
language
they use the language of mathematical
physics the one that most people learn
in high school college maybe you know
and I would say
99.99 of humanity is a flatlander and
they use these words here these are
words that if you use these words to
make your case in physics you are a
flatlander okay so here here they are
these are some of the words they're not
all the the entire vocabulary but if you
use uh words like waves and you're gonna
say oh the wave did this and the other
one and this other thing use the word
ether in any way shape or form you use
the word space time black hole plasma
you know a lot of the electric Universe
uh they can't live without their plasma
below their beloved plasma they also
talk about Vortex uh mainstream usually
talks about Dark Matter dark energy they
use these words such as mass Time Force
charge field
uh they're uh well uh at least the
establishment uses the word particle
quite a bit uh use the dissonance use
the word wave okay and they all like to
do experiments measurements some of them
even do equations
all these folks are Flatlanders none of
this has anything to do with science let
alone with physics okay so we treat them
as Flatlanders and yeah some people say
Bill you're offending us you're
ridiculing uh us and all I can say is no
I treat you with the respect that you
deserve okay so that's how we handled it
here okay so uh here's the mainstream
Flatlanders okay what do they believe in
well here you have a a synthesis okay
you have the flat universities they
believe that the universe is flat okay
this is what they talk about the flat
universe
uh and they include also the quantum
Mechanicals okay so you have these two
groups you have one that tries to unify
them it's known as string theorists okay
and um what's the problem with that well
they are irrational because they are in
the business of moving mathematical
Concepts uh some of some of the words
that you just saw those are mathematical
Concepts what they do they reify them
they turn them into physical objects and
they then begin to move them around and
here you have some of those words time
space time uh energy Mass Field particle
wave black hole dark matter all these
are Concepts none of these are physical
objects you cannot use these terms as
nouns in physics
a big problem with them they use the
atomic model
um created by Niels Bohr and uh Ernst
Rutherford okay which is the planetary
model looks something like that
okay this is uh the hydrogen atom
supposedly it's got a positive proton in
the center proton ball we clarify that
it's got a little electron bead moving
around it or somewhere around it
uh no one knows why the bead the red
electron bead doesn't fall to the
nucleus in fact that's what triggered
quantum mechanics the study of why that
little B doesn't fall to the nucleus but
then there's the question why doesn't it
fly out of the this solar system this
little tiny solar system you know why
does it uh orbit or why does the bead
stand around the proton bowling ball
that's the question
and it doesn't fall to the nucleus it
doesn't run away and we have no idea
what this positive and negative stuff is
all about okay so that's their atom and
of course if you can't answer those
questions and obviously uh you're not
going to have a very irrational Theory
because your hypothesis has not been
constructed properly you do not have the
proper foundations okay
uh what is gravity according to these
people well they use Concepts to uh
explain a concept the concept is known
as gravity gravity is not a physical
object gravity is what we're trying to
explain okay and they use these words
time energy Field Mass they work a lot
on Dimensions okay then uh that's the
usually the um Cosmic World okay quantum
mechanics they have these words that
they've created entanglement
superposition the coherence tunneling
they do not understand any of these
words they do not understand what causes
these effects all they do is they have
named these effects they use them for
technology and the problem there is that
um you know people who say well what is
a quantum computer well a quantum
computer is a computer that uses these
effects
but uh it's not because the the computer
proves quantum mechanics the the
um explanations the physical
interpretations of quantum mechanics uh
what these are are just words that uh
name the the effects that's it it
doesn't get beyond that and so when you
say entanglement well what are you
saying well you're seeing this particle
here affects that one over there uh
without anything in in between
and uh they cannot explain that and if
you cannot explain that you're talking
about black magic okay because you're
saying this affects that without
anything between without no physical
cause that's the issue and then again
general relativity has all these terms
there and the maybe the key one that I'm
interested in is uh the little C equals
a constant it has been measured as a
constant people call it a constant okay
and Einstein proved it's a constant
mathematically in fact it was people who
came before him that did that he just
took the credit but then everybody talks
about FTL faster than light and uh you
say what do you mean faster in line I
thought special relativity was a done
deal it was proven that light travels at
a constant speed and it travels at 300
000 kilometers per second it's the speed
limit of the universe but then people
can't live with that and they say no no
let me let me talk about faster than
light and look you find all these papers
you just do a um a
Google
you Google what I did there the active
and um you look for faster than light
and you find all these papers and I just
put the first couple Pages there a
little bit uh you'll find tons of papers
uh you know these are from the
scientific literature supposing physics
literature and they all talk about
faster than light they want to prove
faster in life they say they observed it
in the lab Etc et cetera Etc everybody
talks about faster than light despite
the fact that Einstein I think set the
record straight saying there is no such
thing as faster than light you cannot
even travel at the speed of light
because if you do you turn into
so-called energy
and uh these people also emphasize
experiments and equations especially
equations they're into math now you
think that this is what science is about
and physics is about experiments and
equations and when I challenge them they
say Bill you're doing philosophy you're
doing semantics they don't like uh me
defining words uh in such a way that
they can't get away from you know from
the definition they want to skirt the
definitions so they don't have
definitions used for physical
interpretations what they've created
this language mathematical language with
concepts of mathematics okay usually
quantitative Concepts and they use them
as physical objects like energy mass and
force field and when you call it their
attention to that they say oh you're
doing semantics
so that's that's the status today uh who
are the dissidents well there's maybe 10
of people out there I would say in the
world that are dissidents that do not
accept the
um
you know the explanations of the
establishment they think something's
fishy about some of those explanations
and they had better it means that it
shows some some degree of intelligence
when you criticize The Establishment
when they talk about black holes Big
Bang dark matter of course you're going
to question a lot of that because it's
all irrational
and but the what the question here is
not the fact that the dissidents
challenge The Establishment there's
nothing wrong there but science is not
about criticizing science is about
explaining what you offer in exchange
that's where science vibrates and this
is where the dissidents fail okay and
this is these are the dissidents here
okay you have these Flatlanders you have
some uh which are from the electric
Universe uh probably the main group that
challenges The Establishment you have
the flat earthers
um but a lot of these people are really
conspiracists not all of them but a lot
of them and they have some political
gripes and they bring them into physics
in other words they have some problems
with the way the governments are run and
they say well everything's a conspiracy
you know everything's a hoax and you
know I kind of draw the line between
politics and science politics and
physics uh I don't think you can uh
automatically you know extend hoaxes and
conspiracies into science you know and
so that's where I usually confront these
people I'm not I'm saying that not
everything in science is a conspiracy
there are interests you know there are
uh uh people who preserve their jobs
their income their careers and they will
do everything to stop anyone who
interferes with that there is a lot of
that going out there but not because of
that is everything a conspiracy
everything's a hoax now these people
usually uh use words such as ether
plasma they use positive and negative
dielectric what is a dielectric what
physical object is that uh they like to
talk about electricity actually current
they talked about the flow of current
you know it's like talking about a flow
of a river as I explained a couple
little weeks ago you know the river's
already flowing so you cannot talk about
the flowing river not in science that's
okay in ordinary speech they talk about
vibration of fields force and charts and
all this other stuff counter space love
that word counter space it's the amount
of space you have to put your beer on
the counter that's more or less what I
think that's that is anyways the one
other problem is they use the same
Quantum atom you know all these people
you know they use this model
the
proton Center and the electron bead
somewhere around it usually they
illustrate it as a um as an orbit okay
sometimes they shouldn't dynamical mode
where the B goes around the proton other
times uh you know they explain that the
little bead stays within what they call
orbitals okay what is an orbital well
it's the orbit of many of uh many orbits
that's what an orbital is they say the
orbital is a region which the electron
all of its on its own cannot jump across
so they have these uh Lanes so to speak
and uh you can find the electron bead
somewhere in there anyways the point
here is that the Flatlanders that this
implant Landers they're no different
than the establishment in the sense that
they use this same atom and this atom
later is denied by everyone they say
well that's not the real atom so which
is the real atom until you can come in
there and tell me what you're you're at
them you know the one you're going to
use in your presentation you cannot tell
me what your atom looks like you cannot
even stop start your presentation you
can now talk about the flow of beads
meaning electricity you cannot talk
about plasma you cannot talk about
ionization because we don't know what
your atom looks like and if you are
going to use this atom then stick to it
and say well this is your atom you can't
at the end of your presentation denied
and say well by the way that Adam I've
used throughout my presentation uh
that's not the real atom okay then show
us your real atom okay before you start
talking that's the way we look at it
anyways
um
flat lenders uh who are dissidents they
typically don't use the word time they
don't like these time things like time
dilation all that stuff they're very
strongly against that okay so they are
in general against all the conclusions
of special relativity uh all this time
dilation length contraction Mass
increase
uh they don't like a lot of the
conclusions of general relativity
especially Big Bang they don't like that
at all uh they don't like space time
they say what do you mean space time
what is space time they don't like the
black hole Dark Matter Dark Energy you
know but what are the issues they have
is that c in many of their theories or a
lot of them at least a lot of these
dissident Flatlanders they think that
little C is a variable that the light
does not travel at a constant speed okay
so this is one of not everyone believes
that but I'm saying that this is one of
the things you'll find out there among
the dissidents okay they usually
emphasize experiments these are people
who like to go to the lab and they say
let me do an experiment Let's do an
experiment to prove your theory or
something along those lines and they're
not too much into math they're not you
know they're not too strong on equations
they usually think that a lot of that uh
should not be uh you know introduced so
much that you should do a little more
um you know physical stuff like go to
the lab and so on anyways these people
also accuse me of doing semantics okay
when I hold them to definition they say
well you're a little too strong on
definitions uh you don't have to be so
um
so stringent you know uh with that was
so rigid you know you should be a little
more flexible Bill no no it's the
flexibility that causes the problems
because when you get around your you
make a definition and then you deny it
by going around it or going on a tangent
that kind of violates your definition
then people can't follow your your
presentation because now you've cheated
you know now you're not holding you're
not being held to your own the
definition that you put forth and so
people say well you know definitions is
that's grammar
that's semantic that's philosophy that's
ontology you know don't bring that in
there we're going to do science here
we're going to do physics this is where
the problem comes
okay so we have some built and I'm going
to show you some examples today the
examples are essentially going to be all
these people who are uh primarily
dissidents and you know what they
propose how they how they think and why
they are Flatlanders okay all these
people are flat lenders they're going to
use words like plasma they're going to
use the word ether and I want to show
you I want to expose the way they think
and so when I'm going to be going
through here are comments and questions
that they asked these past weeks and I'm
going to put them there so that you can
analyze you know how these people think
or don't we can say they don't right
okay here's the first fellow and he puts
this uh issue here he says what's the
confusion Bill are you arguing semantics
or what again they they think this is
semantic we're just using the word
Wizardry here you know uh
um
magic words words of incantation are you
saying energy doesn't exist
you know so so again these people don't
have it right uh they're they've got the
wrong idea of uh of what we're doing
here we're trying to Define these words
and energy is the problem with the word
energy is first there's no solid
definition they have several definitions
of energy the main one is that it's uh
capacity they say capacity blah blah
blah blah blah we don't care what comes
after that it's capacity capacity is not
a physical object so you cannot turn
that into a physical object and say you
transferred capacity
you cannot transfer energy so the
problem comes when they Define it as a
concept and they treat it as a physical
object that's the main problem with all
the language of mathematical physics and
a lot of these people they don't
understand that they say are you doing
semantics or what is this that you're
doing
no it's that you you talk properly we're
going to hold you to you know to talking
properly you cannot start defining a
term as a concept and then start
bringing in as a physical object you
cannot say rock is a is a concept and
then you use it to break a wall you know
or a window or whatever that's where the
problem is and these words are treated
as physical objects during the mo the
time that you do your physical
interpretation that's where it's
irrational that's where the mathematical
physics becomes totally irrational okay
so this is this is the issue okay
here we have another fellow
and he says the following
let me put this up here it says physics
is a application of scientific method to
the study of physical world okay great
physics doesn't examine why something is
meaning cause uh mechanism that's what
he's saying there he says only how it is
meaning he's gonna just describe it it
is completely descriptive just like math
well the only reason that's so that is
so today is that since the 17th century
the mathematicians made everyone believe
that physics is about
um is is about doing math and
um just describing describing
mathematically that's not what physics
is about physics is the physical
interpretation not the mathematical
description and so this person this
individual he believes that physics is
just describing and describing math and
for some unknown reason it's very much
like math yeah of course because math is
not physics physics is not math math is
a description physics is as an
explanation and that's where where we
have a problem when people say well I'm
doing physics and what they're really
doing is mathematical descriptions and
she says this is why they work so well
together they work together because
that's how it was defined for the last
400 years that's the reason it is it
says no one else is using this
definition of physics meaning mine right
and yeah so if you came to this site
you're going to find something different
than what you find out there this is the
only site in the world on the planet
that says physics is physical
interpretations and not mathematical
descriptions if you want these kinds of
answers you should be asking around
philosophy Department not the physics
one the problem there is that yeah like
you see in the picture there the math
guys send you to physics to philosophy
and philosophy send you right back to
math because if you go to any philosophy
site for example the Stanford
encyclopedia philosophy you'll find that
all the concepts related to physics have
come from math that's where the
philosophers got it and the philosophers
strongly believe in what the
mathematicians have fed them so they're
so if you go to philosophy they'll send
you right back to Matt
so it's not that I I can go out there
and uh to the philosophers and say look
let me convince you guys or let me show
you these you guys how this universe
works no they're going to send you right
back to math and they say no the
mathematician's already proved and
through experiment how the world Works
they've got all these equations and then
when you get to the irrational
definitions they say well that's uh
that's uh an interpretation and uh they
get them all from the mathematicians as
well so there's no difference between
mathematics and philosophy okay
and he says you're using philosophic a
definition of explanation in your
definition of physics no we're using
hopefully we're not we're using the a
new definition of physics which is
explanation okay that's what it is and
he says using word games aren't
productive against these people think
that uh we're doing semantics okay they
dismiss all this as semantics as word
games as word Wizardry you know
and that's not what we're doing we're
setting the foundations of physics okay
and the foundations means get your
language straight right up front that's
what physics is about
okay here's another fella and he parrots
The Establishment okay what does this
fall say he says the universe has no
obligation to make sense to us he got
this directly out of the mathematician
they put these words in their in his
mouth
it's not that the Universe has to uh no
obligation to make sense to us you have
to make sense to us the mathematician
who comes up with a theory has to make
sense to us and if he doesn't make sense
then it's irrational that's what it's
called it's not how can you say that
he's explaining how the universe works
when he's telling you in your face that
he does not understand how this universe
works uh entanglement he says it works
by action at a distance whatever that is
it's known as black magic and he says
that's the way you the universe works
you say well I don't understand it
because you haven't given me a mechanism
and again they answer we don't
understand it either
so so we have a problem and he says
there's always going to be another why
you can add at the end of an explanation
no no there's one one mechanism per
question
so we answer one question at a time and
if people can't understand the mechanism
that's why you get the other why okay
but if you explain how the window broke
you say well uh brick went through the
window you've answered the question
period we're done there so there are no
infinite y's not in science there's only
one one explanation one mechanism per y
per question
and the difference between science and
pseudoscience is that science is an
ongoing process to go as deep into the
why as possible the first thing that we
need to say is that nothing in science
nothing in physics in mathematical
physics answers why questions they do
not do y questions so this poor
individual doesn't even have that idea
but then the fact that he says that
science is an ongoing process that is
irrational now science is not an ongoing
process science stops when you explain
once you explain at that point science
stops okay so in the case of physics we
need to explain what we haven't been
able to explain or what the
mathematicians have not been able to
explain in the last three thousand years
which is gravity magnetism electricity
how the atom works and um I must have
missed one uh uh what is it the other
one gravity magnetism electricity the
atom Atomic Works how the atom works and
also how this universe works essentially
light also as well so this is what what
this is what they have to answer and so
far we have no answers from The
Establishment for any of those questions
once we have those answers we're done
with science it's not an ongoing process
you have to stop at some point and
answer the question
and he says if you manage to explain
magnetism better than our current
understanding then congratulations
everyone in the scientific Community
will happily accept a new definition of
magnetism
the new definition of magnetism what do
you mean definition what's this got to
do with definition you have to have an
explanation of the mechanism that's what
you have to do and the second thing is
that no no one in the establishment in
the so-called scientific Community will
ever congratulate you if you tell them
how this universe works because they'll
say that you have not followed
mathematical physics you need equations
they want descriptions they don't want
explanations
so no you will never have uh an answer
okay this is the issue and I said if we
did it the other way any other way you
wouldn't be able to record this video
and upload it to the internet what is he
talking about he thinks technology is
science he thinks technology is
mathematical physics so he says you know
uh computers wouldn't work if quantum
were wrong TPS wouldn't work if general
relativity were wrong this is this is
what this uh individual he's just all
he's doing his parenting he
establishment that's all he's doing
okay so yeah this these are people who
just memorize uh what the establishment
feeds them and they just absorbed and
they never question it they just bow
down to the priest that's what it is
okay here we have uh another fellow and
he says the following
you can see how all these people think
or don't they're called uh Flatlanders
and this fellow says the mechanism is
the invisible magnet and it's dialectic
of positive and negative again you know
they they bring these words positive and
negative they have no idea what that is
but they call it a mechanism okay the
atomic model of positive nucleus and the
negative electron again what are we
talking about where we're talking about
the Rutherford Bohr model they're
talking about that this is what this
file is talking about
and yeah this is not a rational uh model
so the positive negative the nucleus uh
or the proton and the electron this is
an irrational model you cannot start
your presentation with that model
because it's an irrational model first
of all and second because at the end of
the presentation they say well by the
way that was a Dar atom anyways
says our son is an example of the
production of that movement of positive
negative magnetic force as plasma big
word plasma that some called a solar
wind plasma ejected from the Sun what do
you mean plasma ejected from the Sun how
do you eject the concept
plasma is that little moving thing that
you find in between those two magnets
and as you can see it's moving and as
long as it's moving you know you don't
you cannot treat as a physical object
you have to make it stand still and if
you make it stand still you won't get
plasma because plasma is a dynamic
concept and so you cannot eject plasma
from the sun because plasma is not
something that you can eject like a
stone it is a process plasma is like
fire okay and you can say well the fire
comes out of a dragon's mouth well not
in science okay that's in ordinary
speech and in fairy tales okay and so he
says he checked it by the Sun by the
solar wind represents all the elements
produced by the magnetic demiurge of
metaphysics whatever that is okay the
machine is plasma and the ether is the
magnet dielectric that originally spun
up to make the building blocks of all
matter light you don't have to believe
it but it it's a fact well if it's a
fact I gotta believe it I guess right
and I guess this guy uh he just believes
it because he thinks it's a factor
that's what he learned by Road in high
school or wherever and uh he just spits
it out so he talks about words like
plasma and ether and uh uh what
um
be a plasma being ejected by the sun
next thing he's going to say that the
ether vibrates can you believe that
maybe yeah I don't know what he's going
to say okay here's uh another fellow and
what does he say about all these
fantastic words that they use in uh
dissident flant Lander and flatland uh
fellow says the thing between the
particles that makes them pull is
virtual particles okay so heavy you have
all these virtual particles that you
know come into existence and out of
existence constantly and okay let's even
concede that how does that how do all
these in discrete particles pull two
particles together that's the question
explain the mechanism to me and he says
this quantum theory principle answers in
the estimation of quantum theorists
anyway your basic objection now this
doesn't answer anything but see these
people don't even know what they're
talking about if if plasma if uh if
virtual particles uh ether whatever you
want to call it is all these particles
that are in the background okay let's
concede it okay so we have all these
particles in the background how do they
how do particles pull two particles
together that's the show me the
mechanism okay don't know math just show
me the mechanism let's go to the lab and
show me how you pull on the Donkey by
throwing particles at it throwing stones
uh sand whatever you throw at it I want
you to pull the donkey okay when you
explain that mechanism when you show it
to me in the lab well maybe I'll I'll
believe it see I can I can show you how
I can pull with a rope okay I tie this
end okay to the donkey and this to my
hand and I can pull on the donkey and
you can see the mechanism how with a
rope I can pull on the donkey I can
mimic I can simulate the mechanism
do the same thing with any kind of
particles uh virtual particles real
particles fake particles uh conspiracy
theory particles hoax particles any
particle you wish I want you to throw
the particle at the donkey show me how
the donkey is pulled towards you
physically
okay that's the issue so don't tell me
you're gonna pull with virtual particles
you gotta pull two particles you know
two here we have two particles and
you're gonna pull them together by what
by having particles between them how are
you going to pull these together with
particles that's what I want you to
explain the mechanism we illustrate
that's why you know then I'll believe
okay
just show it them show me the mechanism
you know not even God can do that okay
here's another phone he says gravity
then create all the stars and black
holes a collision did The Big Bang
Theory is an utter fact
all these people they talk about fact
they they know everything you know
they're so arrogant they they they know
it all okay so you can't even talk to
them because they're not even listening
they just want to teach and they tell
you Big Bang Theory is a fact okay so
how does he explain this well he says
all energy including gravity okay energy
is a concept gravity is a concept is a
manipulation of field another concept
with energy another concept no energy no
gravity all Concepts so far so far we
haven't learned anything all he said is
that love is made of intelligence which
is made of data which is made of uh who
knows what
okay energy is energized Dark Matter
okay we finally know what energy is it's
energized dark matter I like the fact
that he defines energy with energized
okay that's great the energy a mass
ejects from an object is replaced by the
pressure of space the pressure of space
I thought space was nothing
so this vowel says that space somehow is
a something and it causes pressure like
a piston I guess all this pressure that
that is upon us from space it's
squeezing us right this manipulation
causes the force of gravity okay so so
far we haven't learned anything because
all so far all he's mentioned his
Concepts we don't have a physical object
in that hole in those paragraphs or
those statements there's not a single
physical object he cannot make a movie
of anything that he just put in there
and he's the gut the grand unified
theory is about gravity and space caused
it space causes it space causes gravity
okay gravity is a manipulation of the
field of space with energy
now you learned it finally we know after
three thousand years a theory must be
able to be explained to a six-year-old
and my theory is the one that can do it
absolutely loved it okay how ignorant
can these people be I mean what are
these I asked myself when I read some of
these comments these questions right I
ask myself what are these people doing
in physics what are these people doing
in science they should be in church on
Sundays praying for their salvation they
don't have the mental capacity to to do
physics they don't even know the basics
the foundation's at nothing
they just come up with ears they say oh
I think I got it you know they come up
with a couple things there and they say
I think I know how to explain this
and they say the most absurd things why
in great measure because they don't have
their language straight okay that's that
is what the issue is okay here's another
father talks about the origin of the
universe let's find out how the universe
originated you know matter okay here it
is he says the beginning of the universe
is unknowable
beginning of the universe is unknown no
it is knowable we know it for a fact
there's no question about it Let Me
Explain the origin of the universe so
that you understand it
and you know it okay I'm going to
explain the universe so that there is no
doubt about it okay you learned it here
for the first time okay here it is okay
so up here so we have something to do
let me put on this side okay learn it
right you can uh put it as a prayer
tonight you know when you pray next to
your bed tonight okay read this prayer
okay something that which has shape
nothing that which doesn't have shape
okay something is an antonym of nothing
they are opposites one has shape the
other one is that which does not have
shape okay we got that so far okay now
this is the first law of the Universe I
Want You to memorize this read it every
night uh make it your Lord's Prayer you
know something can't morph into nothing
nothing can't morph into something
we got it
okay you cannot turn something into
nothing you cannot turn nothing into
something how does nothing acquire
spontaneous yours you know uh uh
all of a sudden you know length width
and height and become something
and how does something which has laying
with and hide suddenly lose length width
and height all three dimensions
simultaneously become nothing
if you can explain the mechanism with a
re oh God I'll concede God to you I'll
concede God you want to do it with God
do it with God no problem bring God into
the picture show me how God converts
something into nothing or nothing into
something
if you cannot explain the mechanism you
don't have a rational Theory and you
cannot say something came out of nothing
you cannot talk about the origin you can
now talk about creation with or without
God
because you cannot explain the mechanism
of how something came from absolutely
nothing again with or without God and so
what do the relativists do well they
created a theory known as The Big Bang
Theory and the Big Bang Theory goes more
or less like this okay they say look
the way we see it today the universe is
expanding all galaxies are receding from
all other galaxies the universe is
blowing up before our very eyes it's the
balloon inflation Theory you know you
have this inflating balloon it gets
bigger and bigger and bigger okay and
let me get this out of here
for a second
you know the here you have the balloon
it's getting bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger and because it gets
bigger all the galaxies are on the
surface allegedly this is the general
relativity version so because the
balloon is getting bigger the galaxies
are receiving from each other because
they're like polka dots on a balloon
that you inflate so you inflate it
and the boom gets bigger the dots get
farther away from each other that's the
theory
that's where we are today according to
mathematical physics according to
general relativity
what happens when you uninflate when you
uh pinch the balloon so to speak it
becomes smaller and smaller and smaller
the galaxies come closer and closer and
closer together that means if we were to
run the
um tape you know the videotape backwards
right we would arrive at square one
right and we would see that all the
galaxies somehow converge upon a point
okay Point infinite Mass almost you know
very
um heavy Point very massive Point small
point
and they call that the singularity okay
so this is the starting point so to
speak you know you have the singularity
and it's uh this little you can conceive
of it or think of it as a little point a
little speck of dust that weighs
uh as much as all the matter in the
universe okay think of it like that you
can say almost infinite Mass
in a tiny Speck of dust okay that's what
you're supposed to think of it as
okay
and you say okay where did the Speck of
dust where did this grain of sand come
from this so-called singularity
which is really a zero volume Infinite
Energy You Know It's Just Energy there
in the middle of what because you know
that also that Singularity contains
space as well so we don't know what's
outside of space they say there's
nothing outside of space but that's what
space is nothing so uh we have a little
bit of a contradiction but what's the
problem with a Big Bang Theory The Big
Bang Theory is this they take you to
square number two they take you to frame
number two in the movie okay they don't
take you to frame number one we don't
know how the Little Dot came into being
the little Singularity how did that come
into being
and then what's the black stuff because
if the Little Dot includes space time
and matter what is the black stuff on
which uh against which the little thing
is expanding
and that's when they say well it's not
expending against nothing it's expending
against nothing or there is nothing
outside of it and you say well that's
what space is that's what's inside of
that little dot nothing space so what's
the black stuff that's outside of space
so you gotta Define that you got to tell
me what it is and they say there's
nothing there so we have an object
supposedly the universe which is that
little dot which is uh encapsulated by
nothing which is what space is which is
inside the universe okay so you don't
even have God there on the outside or
Dimensions or anything anyways the issue
is that they take you to frame one they
never to frame two they never take you
to frame one we have no idea how the dot
came into being and the reason they they
the the relatives say well we never go
to frame number one we always go to
frame number two because we cannot tell
you
how that thought came into being
and the issue they're evading is what
the religious folk throw at them they
say ah you're trying to avoid God God
made the singularity
and so they get into this fight well who
made God and they said God's always been
there and blah blah blah you know you
get all these fights between the
religious folk and so-called religious
folk into so-called physicists the
mathematical physicists the Flatlanders
of the mainstream and they get into
these debates on you know whether God
exists or not and they say well we don't
believe in God but we're not going to
tell you what happened frame number one
because we don't know
and we started frame number two which is
where the singularity is already there
and it expanded exploded and we don't
know what happened before that
so we don't have a moment of creation
because we don't know how the
singularity was created okay
and the other guys say well God and what
is god well God's meant is eternal but
for that matter we can just say that
matter
is eternal
doesn't that solve the problem we get
rid of God when you get rid of big bang
both of them we just say matter is
eternal because matter cannot turn into
space
space cannot turn into matter
something cannot turn into nothing
nothing cannot turn into something
spontaneously right all of its own
even with or without a cause I mean
explain the mechanism you cannot explain
the mechanism then we do have an answer
to Creation it never happened
okay we got that
okay we have some people who criticize
the Rope model some of these flat
lenders right we're today's flatlander
today okay and uh one fellow says and
this is a very common question I like to
put this up there because these people
really uh
they start off on the wrong foot they
don't they're not even qualified to ask
questions because they don't even know
what uh what to ask and so they asked
one of the dumbest questions ever and
here it is it says roofs are made of
what ropes of what
what are the roasts made on people ask
this stupid question
and you say well uh are they that lost
go to the hardware store and ask for a
two-strand rope
and when you get it you'll get something
like this right you know what you see
there it's made out of two threads two
strands two wires two strings whatever
you want to call them
and or wander around each other we call
this a rope
uh was that so difficult yeah a rope is
made of two strands I'm sorry that you
never heard of that that you never
learned this in kindergarten
uh maybe you flunked kindergarten
Gardner I don't know
so we have to show them how our theory
is constructed okay and our Theory says
that this is all that exists in the
universe a single closed Lube thread
this is a this is not the real threat
okay by the way this just a simulation
of what we're proposing again we're
saying let me remove this here for a
second
we're proposing that this is all there
is ultimately okay a single closed loop
thread you can simulate it with a rubber
band if you want to explain to your kid
okay that's all there is this red turns
into every atom at every rope that can
that interconnects
any two atoms
that's it see how simple we live in a
very very very simple Universe okay I
know you you've been taught otherwise
you're saying we have a complicated
Universe we cannot understand anything
we'll never figure it out science is an
ongoing process of discovery where we
don't discover we never find we only
seek
no at some point the buck stops here you
have to explain and to explain you have
to have foundations
definitions and the objects that you're
going to use to explain your theory okay
that's the way it works your mechanism
your you know you're going to explain a
Cause
okay so this is the starting point and
this is more or less what it looks like
here's a synthesis of that okay for
those of you who are new to the site
okay here it is we have the signal
closed looped thread which is the rubber
band I just showed you okay it twines
around itself all around the universe
and it creates that universe that you
see on the upper right hand corner all
atoms in the universe are physically
connected to all other atoms in the
universe all these atoms form galaxies
stars planets asteroids comets
everything you can think of even the gas
that's uh interstitial you know between
galaxies Interstellar Intergalactic all
that stuff so we're seeing all this if
you were to unwind that entire universe
that you see there it would look like
that single closed loop thread on the
upper left hand corner okay so this is
this is what we're proposing this is
what we're saying the universe is what's
the black stuff in the background that's
known as space what is space space is
nothing what is nothing it's the
opposite of something what is the
opposite of something that which has no
shape okay so space has no shape space
is nothing nothing is a concept okay do
we have that nothing is a concept
okay and no matter is not really
floating in a concept
that matters simply related to matter
okay it's not related to the background
the background simply forms this
backdrop that uh kind of chisels you
could say matter we're only concerned
about matter not about the black stuff
because the black stuff is not there
okay it's uh it's not a thing
okay it's not a container okay so what
happens with these uh interconnected
atoms well there you see it on the lower
and left hand corner it's in a dynamic
mode you have the 2D version and you
have the 3D version
okay of the atom the simplest atom which
is an electron shell that encapsulates
the proton star they're connected by a
rope and as the atom expands and
contracts it torches the rope and that
is known as light
okay that's the in a synthesis you know
that's the in in few words that's what
the proposal is okay that's what we're
proposing that's how the universe works
that's what light is and uh here we have
the construction of the atom okay so
that you can see it better okay you have
two threads one twines around and
encapsulates the one in the center that
comes from every atom in the universe
it's a little star in the center there
okay so you have all the ropes in the
universe converging upon our atom they
all crisscross in the center and they
form this entity which as you can see
has ropes converging upon the edge the
uh electron shell as we call it and one
of the threads goes around the other one
goes through the center okay so this is
the construction of our atom it's
constructed out of the same material the
same threads that form the ropes and we
have a single closed boot thread in the
entire universe that is our proposal
bottom left you see our 2D atom here you
see it bigger that's what it looks like
ropes converging upon the electron shell
and the one thread goes to the center of
the atom which forms all the threads
from the universe converts upon that
Center and form the proton star okay and
immediately people think about C touch
they think about our experience in our
macro world and we have to correct them
there because we say that first of all
an object is not that which you can see
or touch it's that which has shape the
Rope the atom the threads all have shape
okay but they do not have the ability to
see or touch especially touch okay they
can't touch each other they go right
through each other
and people have a lot of problem with
that they said what do you mean it goes
right through each other because it
offends their everyday experience but
again an object is not that which you
can see touch it's that which has shape
we meet their definitions it these
things have shaped the thread the Rope
the atoms they have shape but they
cannot be touched by humans or between
them and that's a part of the
foundations people say Bill you're
avoiding the question
uh you're you're just making uh an ad
hoc assumption
and we have to make that assumption we
have to make that assumption because we
have to explain Mother Nature's Universe
not the one you want
not the one of our macro world not the
one of our ordinary or everyday
experience we have to explain why this
pencil right falls to the floor
okay and it you know and you see nothing
above and nothing below and you can you
can't touch anything above or below
and so hopefully whatever's here here
right uh is untouchable
and if you can touch it uh that'd be
great you know but we can't touch it and
so we have to make our assumption our
you know the foundation of this Theory
we have to make it Untouchable to mimic
to simulate Mother Nature's world not
the one we want not the one we say well
how come I can't see or touch it well
because it's Mother Nature's world that
you're analyzing her world you cannot
see or touch which is a mediators that
cause this and if you say there is
nothing here nothing here then you're
doing black magic you're doing by
everything by action at a distance and
we do not understand your mechanism okay
so that's the issue
okay uh another fellow brings up another
issue and again all these are
Flatlanders the way they think or don't
okay this fellow says you state the Rope
connections between objects changed from
a coaxial to becoming spread out
increasing the number of independent
connections exactly in your model the
number of rope connections to all atoms
don't increase and the tension and
length of the ropes remain fixed correct
the how does changing the angle of the
ropes add acceleration to an object so I
guess as well doesn't understand okay
he's never uh
uh visualize this what he's trying to
figure out there any real physical I
like the arrogance they say any real
world physical examples of change in
angle producing an acceleration between
objects using ropes of fixed length
number and tension aha
okay so this is what he's bringing up he
also brings up the next issue which I
think is same fellow he says you forgot
to draw the trillions of rows connecting
the Astra to every star in the universe
you also have not justified why the
astronaut would fall towards the Earth
in the first place are there leprechauns
pulling on those ropes what about the
leprechauns pulling in every other
direction
okay so the first thing we have to
educate this poor fellow on is uh
Newton's equation I guess he's never
been familiar she's never been you know
educated on Newton's equation it's got a
little D at the bottom and not R like
the uh
people from mathematical physics uh put
down there it's not an R it's not a
radius okay and there's a lot of reason
for that I've talked about that in the
past it's D for distance always okay
never put a little r there like the
mathematicians do okay now what is it we
wait you have weight and you can see uh
the weight of an astronaut 25 kilograms
there outside of the earth is different
than him being closer to the Earth and
the only thing that's changed is
distance okay so he's at a certain
distance at 25 kilograms in a 20 in a
different distance at 50 kilograms okay
so he weighs differently depending on
simply location weight is a static
concept really it's location dependent
if the astronaut moves one millimeter
one inch one foot one yard closer to the
Earth he already weighs more just by
changing his location he has a different
weight
and people don't always understand that
in fact the people who don't understand
it are people from Newton all the way to
Hawking you know all these people uh who
are mathematicians they don't understand
that that weight is a static concept
weight is location dependent different
location different weight you move one
inch closer to the Earth without moving
them you could just stay there in space
you would wait differently than if you
are farther out that's how simple it is
and this all doesn't understand and so
it's very hard to talk to people who do
not understand Newton's equation to
begin with okay so here let me show you
this and see if we can clarify that with
a little bit here it is this is how
gravity works okay this might answer his
questions there you have a cube and a
cylinder okay as the cylinder approaches
the cube okay you can see what's
happening with the ropes connecting one
atom in the cylinder to several atoms in
the cube when the when the
cylinder was farther out all the ropes
were on the same axis they were one
right it went right behind the other in
other words they were all on the same
axis because the atoms are all aligned
okay but what happens when the cylinder
approaches the cube just by location
just by changing the distance you can
see what's happening to the ropes they
immediately fan out and each rope is
acting independently that's what we mean
by independent ropes the ropes have not
appeared out of nowhere the ropes were
not created the ropes are not pulling
the word pull is really outlawed we use
pull for the concept known as gravity
but not for what's happening between
each of the ropes the ropes are under
tension and tension is not a force for
tension is not a pull or a push tension
is uh means that no one wins the tug of
war so those ropes are under tension
which his character which is really
defined by the velocity of light see
okay and all that's happened here is
that the ropes fan Out and because they
found out each one acts independently
and then at the bottom you see uh
another simulation of what we're talking
about we're saying when the cylinder and
the cube are very very far apart you can
see all the ropes form a single coaxial
it's like it's we're a single rope so
distance is very important when we're
talking about gravity but as the
cylinder approaches the cube or vice
versa you can see what's happening to
the ropes they fan out and that's the
acceleration of gravity on the right
hand side you see on top the way the
mathematicians talk about a spoon they
say Well it falls and there's nothing
pulling or pushing on it and on the
bottom right you see our version which
is every atom of the spoon is connected
to every atom of the Earth
as the spoon falls all the ropes fan out
and that's the cause of the acceleration
of gravity that's what causes
gravity that is gravity right there okay
and here's a an experiment that not an
experiment really it's a simulation
people are going to say oh Bill you're
running an experiment okay what you see
I made this device because I use it as a
didactic tool to teach okay this is just
so that you can visualize gravity which
is what this file says tell me how you
know you produce gravity it looks
something like this okay see if I can
okay this is the device okay I'll see it
there you can see it may be better okay
this is the device and I'm going to set
it in motion okay with a little video
because it's uh probably you'll see it
better through the video okay so you can
see how gravity works okay so keep an
eye on the device here you'll see how
gravity works okay this is what we're
proposing okay we're seeing that as uh
an object approaches a center of gravity
maybe the Earth maybe the sun whatever
you can see what happens to the ropes be
behind the hand they form a single
coaxial and in front they
open up okay so when we push it forward
you can see what's happening to the
ropes they change the Angles and any
rope that is was on that same axis would
be tugging or would be acting
independently okay but look what happens
behind the hand they all form a single
coaxial and when you move outwards you
see the same effect okay so again this
is just a simulation okay you have your
Newtonian gravity on the left hand side
and what I call the linear regime on the
right hand side okay one more time there
it is
okay just to see just to show you how
the simulation works okay simple device
that can tell you what happens with the
angles of the ropes as an object
approaches the Earth or maybe the Sun
and what happens behind it okay so when
you leave the solar system you're going
to enter that linear regime okay it's
going to be almost a straight line all
the way to Alpha Centauri or the next
star or whatever okay
okay so this is just a simulation so
that you can see
uh how we're uh imitating this how we're
simulating you know gravity with this
the angles okay and of course when you
change the angles what you're doing is
getting ropes that are now out of
alignment they're not on the same axis
any longer now they separate and now
each one is acting separately because
you have an atom at the end of each one
of those ropes
okay so distance is a very important
thing yeah the moon pulls on us but the
Moon is so far away a little over a
light second away from us and so it's
influence on us is very little because
it's almost a single coaxial more or
less
okay so this is how you're supposed to
see it
uh the Moon is essentially Tethered to
the Earth
okay uh now fellow he brings up another
issue he says gravity goes right through
things
uh well that's from Professor Mueller
Professor Mueller which I talked about a
couple weeks ago and he says this guy
doesn't believe it he says like it goes
through a wall
yeah you never figure this out that
gravity goes through the wall it pulls
on him right through the wall
the Earth is pulling on him right
through the ground the floor that he's
stepping on he never realized this and
he's ignorant people they come here and
they want to teach you something or they
want to laugh you know they make fun of
you and then they and then they complain
when I make fun of them see so yeah
they're very ignorant very arrogant
people
and it says the object the wall doesn't
move you're right yet the motion of the
astronaut on an object is affected you
didn't even spell that right I can't
find a reason in rationale again didn't
spell that one right in the explanation
okay something to do with a moving
concept called angular momentum between
objects or the wall is connected to the
ground the astronaut isn't
again these people are so ignorant and
this comes from Mr Mueller who said the
following okay he says
you know uh professor at uh Berkeley he
says every atom on the earth is pulling
on every atom of you you're also pulling
on it the amazing thing about gravity is
that it goes right through things
it goes through things and people should
really memorize all that they should
pray every night using this prayer every
animal on earth is pulling on every atom
of you you're also pulling on it
the amazing thing about gravity is that
it goes right through things
and people have problems understanding
what I just put up there you see maybe I
should leave it there for an hour until
you memorize it okay yes this comes out
of Newton's equation you can't avoid
Newton's equation Newton's equations are
well
firmly set in place okay so uh you know
you can do all the experiments you want
you'll come up with Newton's equation
okay Newton's equation is right on the
money
and you know you're being pulled right
through the floor by the Earth every
time you jump why are you pulled
downwards something is pulling you and I
guess uh from underneath the floor why
don't you why can't you jump to the Moon
and this file never discovered that the
gravity goes right through the wall and
pulls on you now it doesn't pull you
through the wall because there's not
enough matter sideways all the matter is
underneath us and you're very close to
that matter you're also pulled by the
moon but you're very far away from the
Moon that's why you don't fall to the
Moon that's why when you jump you're
pulled more to the earth into the moon
some of these people don't understand
even these basic things and they claim
to know how this universe works they
want to teach you know and they want to
laugh at you the way you the the ideas
that you have
and they're so ridiculous because they
don't even know the basics they don't
even know if they don't even understand
the foundations okay I mean if they
would have gone to high school at least
at least they would know understand some
of these things but they don't even have
this base at this Foundation
okay and another fellow says I wonder
why the space station doesn't actually
fall down and how come it orbits the
earth without propulsion
you're wrong uh there is a propulsion
okay so the space station the ISS right
International spaces does have
propulsion okay and so I put in there
and answer the ISS does have propulsion
it must accelerate forward it travels
faster than the spin of the Earth
the air spins and this thing goes you
know several times 16 times around 16
times as fast as the spin of the earth
it goes through the top of your house 16
times during the day while the uh Earth
the whatever the cloud that would go all
around would go to us with a spin of the
earth okay
so yeah this goes faster than the spin
of the earth it travels around the Earth
around 16 times faster right the ISS is
a kite
let me repeat that the ISS and every
satellite you see out there
is a kite every probe that's ever
orbited the Earth uh the shuttles uh
kite they're all kites
every single one is a kite every single
atom of that device is stuck to every
single atom of the Earth
that's what's keeping it in orbit
but if it just stands there it'll fall
to earth like you know just like this
you know this is just you know if if it
stands still it doesn't move forward
it'll fall
but if uh like Newton said if this moves
forward and moves at a faster fast
enough rate
fast enough speed then it'll stay in
orbit
Newton showed this 400 years ago come on
guys
and so every atom that comprise it the
ISS is bound by electromagnetic ropes to
every atom that comprises the earth the
earth swings the ISS around okay
okay like this
okay like uh a boy swinging ball at the
end of a string and here I'm gonna
illustrate that for you okay a little
bit here's the ISS just standing still
this is the version that mathematical
physics would show you they say look the
ISS is is just for no reason whatsoever
just up there and it doesn't fall to
Earth and for some reason we have to
accelerate it you know propulsion okay
and uh what we're proposing we're saying
No this is what's happening okay that's
the real thing that we just can't see
those ropes you can't see or touch them
that's what's holding on to the ISS
that's why the ISS does not leave the
Earth okay so that's the issue and here
you see okay this is a what it what
you're seeing there is the ISS going out
around much faster than the earth the
earth spins around and you can see that
um yeah the ISS just goes much faster
than the Earth Earth it's like a boy is
spinning again a uh ball at the end of a
string that's that's everything works
like that in the universe the Earth is
also swung around by the Sun the Moon
and Sun is swung around by the Earth so
and down the line we're swinging the ISS
around that's why it doesn't leave the
solar system why because what did Mr
Mueller say Professor puller he said
every atom of the ISS is bound to every
atom on Earth every atom on Earth is
bound to every atom of the ISS
got it so the Earth swings the ISS
around like a boy swinging a ball at the
end of a string and here you see it a
little bigger and I put it up there so
that you can see it better give me a
second here there it is ah
I thought I had it right
give me a second here there it goes okay
so that's what's happening okay the ISS
is is a kite that's all it is it's being
swung around the earth as the Earth
rotates
simple that's our Theory
okay
any questions
put them there and we'll address it next
time those are for people flat lenders
who don't yet understand what the Rope
model is all about
okay we also have the etheris and these
people are yeah Flatlanders they believe
in The Ether they introduce The Ether
for everything now I do clarify and I
have clarified that the establishment
also Believes In The Ether The Ether has
never abandoned us in the last three
thousand years because everybody thinks
that there is some kind of entity out
there which they call The Ether that
either vibrates or serves as the
foundation for light maybe even for
Gravity it's the background energy it's
the cosmic background radiation they've
got all these names the false vacuum
space time they have all these names for
it it's known as The Ether it's never
changed okay it's always been the ether
okay and um so I also mentioned a couple
weeks ago what any etherist has to
answer
these are your action items you can't
put a comment unless you answer these
questions otherwise your your comment or
your question or whatever you put down
is uh No Nonsense you have to tell me
what the ether is you have to Define The
Ether if if you're going to Define if
it's concept if it's an object I want
you to point to it and here are the
action items here it is okay is it an
object is The Ether an object or is it a
concept that's the first question you
got to answer okay for that you need to
know what an object is what a concept is
so you you don't know what these are you
got to define those words as well you
got to tell me how an object is
different than a concept a concept
that's different than an object and here
we have definitions we work first from
definitions every word in the dictionary
is either
a uh an object or a constant can't be
both okay so either God is a concept or
God is an object God is intelligence
love whatever or God is that guy with a
magic wand in his hand okay so if it's a
thing it's a man it's a wizard fine
point to him draw him make a picture of
him a statue whatever he is
show us what what God is if you think
God is a concept just a an abstract
concept and that's what you pray to you
pray to intelligence you prayed a lot of
uh spirit whatever it is fine we need to
know which one God Is So tell us what
ether is is ether an object is it a
concept if it's an object we want you to
we want to see something in front of us
with a background when I see some shape
if it's a concept Define it that's how
simple it is okay
shape 0.2
uh concept defined back black and white
that's all it is okay so um ether is
either equal to space
or then eight it can't be both
so you can't say you can't use it in
both ways you can't say either is space
and also is within space now is if space
is a container of ether
is something separate from space
and if you say that space is ether there
is no difference well then you have to
tell us that as well it's got to be one
or the other it can't be both and that's
not very clear to all ether is okay you
have these different sects okay
um
is it is it finite or infinite I mean if
if the ether is equal to space is that
finite or infinite and if it's infinite
it's not an object it's not a thing you
can't use it as a thing you can't say
the I'm going to vibrate The Ether
because you haven't defined it as a
thing so it had better be finite but if
it's finite then you got to tell me
what's on out on the outside of it
see how simple it is very simple
straightforward okay and does it Move If
It Moves it's a thing
okay but you can't say a little bit of
it moves you can't say the ethers all
this background that covers the entire
universe but I'm going to shake a little
bit of it and call that the shaking of
The Ether
if you're going to shake The Ether you
got to move the whole thing
and good luck with that one you know
you're moving the whole thing you know
like if it were like this like if we're
a single thing you're moving it like
that you're gonna shake the entire
universe that's a big wave but if you're
gonna move a little piece of it a little
region of ether don't call it the ether
now you're talking about something else
now you're talking about The Ether made
of segments of particles of parts
that's not the ether the ether's the big
shebang and the whole shebang okay
okay and uh again uh if it moves with
respect to what so these are the action
items that people who propose The Ether
have to come through with they have to
answer these questions before they can
give their presentation we don't care
about their Theory at all really we we
want you to identify the ether spend two
years on your ether because we still
don't know what it is if you said it's a
fluid that that doesn't explain anything
you know by saying it's a fluid it's
like saying water is a fluid yeah and
what is water
what's a fluid yeah I mean you know
point to it okay if it's if it's a fluid
then it's got to have shape okay
and if it has shape I need to know
what's on the outside of it so don't
tell me it's just the fluid
it's a moving fluid a vibrating fluid or
whatever
okay so here's the first individual he
says uh these are the same thing as
plasma
okay so ether is that plasma that I
guess all those little bees that you see
there okay that's the plasma what is
plasma plasma is a dynamic concept
that's what plasma is okay and why
because uh which what plasma is is
ionization of every atom or most of the
atoms in that
pile of sand that you see there so
plasma is something that is always in
motion because it's ionized and
ionization is a process not a thing
there is no such stand-alone thing
called ionization ionization is a
process where an uh an atom loses or
gains an electron and that process
requires at least two frames of the
movie you cannot synthesize it in one
frame therefore if plasma is ionization
plasma is also a moving thing it
requires two frames of the universal
movie okay but he says is inside Space
so he's saying if it's inside Space he's
saying space is some kind of container
now we need to know what's outside of
space okay we know what's inside it's
plasma what's outside of space but then
he says space is nothing
so if space is something now you say
space is nothing you know space is a
container it's something but now he says
space is nothing so he's got a
contradiction why because he never
defined a word something or nothing he
never defined these two words so he has
no idea what something is what nothing
is and he just uses these words thinking
you know what he's talking about let's
go into his tiny brain is there part of
the universe which is empty yeah between
your ears that's what's empty okay he
says uh empty empty is what space is
space is nothing and he says is there a
part of universe that is empty yeah let
me let me illustrate what he's missing
why there is part of the universe which
is empty completely empty here it is
okay
matter is the stuff you see the black
stuff is not matter the black stuff is
emptiness there is nothing there because
that is the definition of nothing which
is that which has no shape otherwise you
would not be able to see the atoms and
oros that interconnect the atoms okay
they wouldn't have said you would have a
single block of matter
instead of matter being seen in pieces
like that if space did not exist is if
this nothingness did not serve as a
backdrop that's the issue okay so yeah
there is uh something called nothing and
and that's what you call emptiness and
that's that black stuff there because
you have to Define what the word
something and nothing is the stuff you
see uh moving here that's called
something and that has shape and all of
that has shaped the little balls which
are the atoms and the atoms that
interconnect them and the black stuff is
the nothing that which doesn't have
shape and serves as a backdrop to that
which has shape and nothing is what
chisels something so to speak okay okay
we got that
okay so the file says ether is not
nothing it is something okay thank God
for that right okay ether is a soup
inside the nothing yeah again you can't
be inside the nothing because instant
nothing is a concept you can't be inside
a concept okay plasma ether is more
concentrated the further you get away
from a magnetic field because the
magnetic field repels it so here we have
a field which is a constant that repels
the plasma which is another concept we
have Concepts repelling Concepts we have
love repelling intelligence that's what
we have here and nobody's been to the
Moon oh Jesus because why the area
around the Earth's Magneto speed
magnetos magnetosphere is full of plasma
okay so I guess we can't go through
plasma is that what it is
I mean who knows what's going through
this poor guy's little brain
but what are these people doing science
they don't have the ability to stay
within science they don't have the
foundations
they have to take uh kindergarten 101
before they can come into science okay
okay here's another fellow he says
either can be treated like a Continuum
oh okay because it is made of a an
infinite amount of objects
okay well that's not what a Continuum is
a Continuum is something made of a
single piece it's the opposite see this
was uh Aristotle's notion of Continuum
something made of many parts because
that's the mathematical notion of
Continuum in physics it's the opposite
Continuum means it's made out of a
single piece and not made of Parts uh
you know pile of sand is not a Continuum
even though every grain is touching each
other's grain assuming that were the
case or water is touching you know every
molecule is touching every other
molecule that's not a continuum that's
called discrete or segmented made of
parts
continue made of a single piece okay he
says most ether theaters have defined
ether as being made of many possibly
infinite amount of particles okay now
you can't have infinite amount of
particles because infinite is an
irrational terms term infinite means
you're still counting okay if there's
infinite number of whatever okay so we
don't introduce the word infinite into
into science or much less into physics
think the is ether is continuous well if
it's continuous it's made out of a
single piece then it would be uh
continuous otherwise The Ether is made
of parts and it's not continuous it's
segmented middle parts uh who you know
made of points whatever you want to call
them
continuums aren't actual objects uh yeah
it could be if it's made out of a single
piece yeah could be but rather
mathematical representations of a group
of objects behavior in a single object
okay so you're talking about Behavior
not talking about structure a Continuum
is not an actual fluid because fluids
are made from more than one thing uh
yeah so uh the guy went completely
around in circles and we don't know what
he said that's that's essentially it
okay here we have another phone he says
what he says the fish analogy which I
used the other day and there you see it
on the right it completely wrong way the
wrong way to represent any version of
ether yikes
yikes a light wave should not be thought
of as a separate object like a fish
so you can see these guys are so
ignorant so arrogant they know
everything okay mechanical wave is a in
a medium is merely a behavior of that
Medium okay so he's saying uh we have an
ocean and it behaves somehow okay a wave
travels wave travels how can a wave
travel when a wave is a concept you know
you can say though the flag traveled not
that the waving of the flag traveled
okay so that's when they say oh you're
doing semantics Bill say you're using
word Wizardry no I'm just repeating what
he said he's saying a wave travels no
such physical object called a wave
that's where the problem is he's
introducing words of ordinary speech or
of mathematical physics into science he
can't do that okay there is no physical
object called wave you can't use the
word wave in science
but he says a wave travels he's treating
it like an object through a medium
through a medium is not enough uh three
medium is not an object okay it's a
behavior correct a wave is a behavior
it's a it's a verb that's why we don't
treat it as a as an object and we can't
say that a wave travels okay it's just a
wave isn't some separate thing inside a
medium okay then what is it it's the
medium doing things so wave is a verb
okay it's what the medium does so you
need to identify the medium and either
you identify the medium you know the
entire ether for example the entire
ocean say That's The Ether the whole
Ocean or you identify a portion of it
which is what you're going to be
vibrating with what you're going to be
waving and in that case you can't see
the ocean is waving you can say the
water in some location some region of
the ocean is waving but you can't see
the ocean is waving because that's not
what you're talking about okay looking
out onto an ocean with waves coming into
the shore there's nothing there but
water behaving yeah water behaves
correct now we've got the right word
water okay
you can say water you can say molecules
you can say atom but you cannot say the
ocean is behaving okay the wave are
traveling do they exist without the
water right you got that part right so
what's so let's go slowly with this fall
let's see if he understands what he said
okay here we have it here's uh the ocean
okay let's go slowly let me remove this
one here here's a
here's the ocean
okay single block of water okay or
matter whatever you want to call it
let's assume it's static we're just
looking at a single frame of the ocean
cross section of time okay we're looking
at just one ocean one that's all we have
there okay one one picture snapshot of
the ocean okay now uh let's go in there
and wave something okay here's one wave
inside the ocean that's just one way
okay is the ocean waving
no
water is waving somewhere in the ocean
so we should not talk about the ocean at
all we cannot talk about The Ether which
is what the ocean represents the word
ocean here is the word ether okay and
they're saying something is vibrating
within the ether
the water we want to know what the water
of the ether is that's the question okay
I hope we get the question right at
least okay so we had the ocean okay and
that's the ether okay now we're going to
vibrate a little region of the ocean
which he called what water okay so what
do we call a region of The Ether
that's the million dollar question
because here you have many ways see if
we can put this up here that's many ways
that's the ocean with many waves each
one with a little region okay but that
but you know this is the issue the issue
is here we have a single region of the
ocean
he called it water he says you can't
have whey without the water correct we
don't care about the word ocean we don't
care about the ether now we're talking
about the peace the segment the region
of that ether which is moving in the
case of the ocean he calls it water we
need to know what water is in case of
The Ether
that's the million dollar question okay
okay so uh
if if you have many waves like you just
saw this is what you have
there you have The Ether you have all
these regions of the ocean and they're
vibrating and when they say look it's uh
the The Ether is vibrating well no The
Ether is not vibrating what's vibrating
there is every region of the ether is my
brain you see the water molecule so to
speak of The Ether which are vibrating
we need to know what the water is
that you call that you know the
composite of which we call Ether okay
and um
and so here uh if you look at one of
those regions you expand it this is what
you would find okay they say well the
vibration of The Ether no no that's the
vibration of the water within the ether
and again you have to tell me what the
white dots are you can't call that ether
because you're talking about a region of
The Ether and for that you need to
Define that's what you need to do you
need to tell us what the physical object
is and until you can identify the water
of the ocean the water of The Ether
right uh you can't even start your
presentation
okay another fella He suggests an
experiment okay this is what they in
there is an easy way to solve this okay
good go to space with a clear air proof
waterproof ball okay open it in outer
space and close it back to have the ball
filled with ether okay bring the ball
under water and open it if a bubble
forms in space is a medium ether if you
see fume waves then space is a gas if
nothing happens when the ball fills with
water then space is a vacuum
okay so uh this is what uh people have
going through their brains they have all
these things that they think they can
prove through and experiment what the
spaces out there which they call The
Ether which they say is within the space
and the space is a container and they
don't know what's outside of this
container giving it form they talk about
infinite infinite particles they say
these space is infinite The Ether is
infinite then they say we're going to
vibrate The Ether and they're not
vibrating in The Ether they're vibrating
the water within the ocean
so they have all these contradictions
they never resolve these they never yeah
and this is a question of rationality
you have to resolve these issues before
you can give your presentation before
you can talk about The Ether or anything
else but they don't do this they just go
directly in there and if you question
these things and you're doing semantics
bill
you're you're doing philosophy
ontology whatever it's called these days
okay here's another fellow okay let's
get up here he says life doesn't require
a medium he's saying uh we don't need
this ether thingy
I guess he says they proved the
non-existence of The Ether okay of this
um of this medium there is no medium out
there okay and uh and so here you have
light and we talk about the motion of
light in fact he says light is moving
the fastest in a vacuum light slows down
in a medium okay that's what light does
through the water you know through the
ether fine but uh he doesn't tell me
what light itself is but he says it
doesn't require a medium so he's talking
about light moving
and how can light move if light is not a
thing if it does if it's not if it's not
mediated by something okay if light has
no medium what is it that is moving
nothing
is it a concept that's moving
so this is the issue you have to define
the word motion and that's why this guy
is not even in kindergarten physics you
know he's he doesn't understand what
motion is you need two locations at
least of a medium to talk about motion
that's the definition of the word motion
once you have that definition you cannot
say light does not require a medium
because then what is it that is moving
what is it that occupies two location
what occupies two frames of the
universal movie if there's nothing there
okay if it's a concept or who knows what
he's got in his mind and then yes uh you
see there the little C is equal to
frequency times wavelength that's the
equation of a rope okay that's what the
mediator is that's what's moving that's
what's vibrating in this case torquing
okay and uh all we have is a difference
between uh segments of the Rope for a
given length of rope you have more uh
links and uh the links are shorter and
if you unwind the Rope well then you
have fewer links and the Rings are
links are longer and that's what that
equation represents C equals frequency
times wavelength is number c is equal to
number of links and wavelength is the
link length that is the equation of a
rope only a rope can simulate that
equation okay
so uh that's that's where we're at and
here uh you have a definition of what an
object is and what motion is okay an
object is that which has shape you need
to have shape and so to say that light
has no medium
or is not mediated by anything is
irrational because you're going to talk
about motion and so the question is what
is it that moved lotion motion two
locations of an object and there you
have a film of of the movement of
something and a film of the movement of
nothing which is what this fellow
proposes okay so again you know I don't
know what these uh people really have in
the back of their minds when they talk
about light moving how can light move if
it's not a thing you need to have a
thing for to conceptualize motion and
here you have uh let me make this bigger
give me a second here
you have uh why the
um
why the Rope is a good model for light
because uh light is it has that equation
the velocity of light is 300 000
kilometers per second okay it's a
constant and it's a constant between any
two atoms it doesn't matter what object
uh
it belongs to and it doesn't matter what
light goes through
between any two atoms in the universe at
least in the known universe Right light
um has the same speed the same torque
because all you're doing is changing
frequency in exchange for wavelength IF
frequency meaning more links are there
then the link the links are shorter and
vice versa the links are longer you have
fewer links and what you have here is
you can see white light coming in there
and again this is just a a picture of
what happens through a prism when light
goes through the prism you can see that
between atoms the
links are of different wavelengths there
are a number different number of links
and what comes out is all these colors
and what are colors well they're
different link lengths and different
what we call frequencies meaning number
of links okay so for a given rule length
right you can torque it more and torque
it less and and you're going to get
different colors meaning different
frequencies and this is easily shown you
know with a robe model is perfect there
you have a few links I don't know how
many
two or three right now we're going to
talk it torque it some more it's always
the same piece of length that's all the
Rope I've got okay I'm I'm not
introducing more open here okay now you
have more links and each link is smaller
or shorter okay and now we un-torque it
now the Links become longer and each
there are fewer links and what we have
this is the equation of a rope C equals
frequency times wavelength it's always
the same amount of rope okay so for this
given length of rope you can simulate
why light always is a constant between
any two atoms all you did was change the
number of links that's it okay that's
that's the theory now some people say
well uh you know if you torque it more
the the Rope kind of shrinks right and
becomes shorter overall right the the
Rope is a little longer if you have you
know the links like this right the
longer links then if you torque it you
know it tends to pull all the links
closer together also and yeah the answer
is very simple remember how the atom is
constructed it's constructed by the same
threads so the uh atom slides through
these threads and the threads are being
fed into the Rope so the slack is taken
up from the atom which is taken up from
another rope which is taken up from
another atom which is taken up from
another rope
when you pull that a rope in a sense
you're pulling on the entire universe
that's what you're doing the atoms are
sliding along the ropes okay and because
the ropes construct the atoms so there's
no mystery the the Rope can become a
little longer a little shorter when it
torques more and torques less because
um it's borrowing uh Slack from atoms
which are buying it from another rope
which are buying from another atom and
so on Down the Line
okay uh here we have another fellow and
he says uh all of the uh all of those
have motion because they are all made
out of moving molecules so I showed the
other day how solid liquid and gas is
something you point to you know there
you have a liquid uh we took a snapshot
of it does that have shape and the
answer is yes yes you take a snapshot of
gas whatever gas if you could see it and
it has shape and same with a solid and
this is what I was trying to say that
plasma and fire also uh have shape when
you take a snapshot of it and that
nevertheless uh you know fire and plasma
have stuff that's moving in there
they're Dynamic entities you could say
and but for that matter so it's gas
liquid and solid because they are made
of atoms atoms which have electrons and
the electrons are also moving within
those atoms that's his argument okay it
says all molecular objects are processes
by the same standard liquid and gas and
body motion too fluid motion well again
as one of the problem with these people
they they've never taken uh you know
High School physics or kindergarten
physics that's that's why I look at it
okay so let's educate this follow let's
go slowly because you know they have
problems understanding all this stuff
okay
here you're going to teach the cling on
your language you put to a tree
are you thinking about the atoms that
comprise the tree and whether the atoms
and the electrons within the atoms are
moving
when you look at the word tree
now you point and you say tree tree is
that thing there you can take a snapshot
of it you can make a picture of it you
can bring a mock-up of it you bring your
actual tree
you're not thinking of the atoms that
comprise the tree and whether they're
moving or not or whether there's a wind
that moves the tree you the the word
tree the word tree
represents a static concept okay it is a
static concept the word tree the word
right three you point to and you say
tree it's an object and you're not
thinking of what it's made out of and
whether it's moving
okay the word tree does not embody
motion
we got that uh I know it's kindergarten
stuff for us uh Advanced people but you
know for some of these people it's it's
a it's a big jump in their intelligence
in their understanding okay here now
you're going to teach them the word
table okay you're gonna teach them the
word table what is a table well tables
what I point it to it's that thing over
there you know I point and say tape
that's the way you do it and are you
thinking about what the table is made
out of uh whether those atoms are moving
the electrons are moving within atom no
you're not thinking about any of that
the word table does not embody motion
the word wall the word Rock None of
these embodies Motion in the word Rock
in the word table and the word chair
wall Etc Brown
those those are static concept the words
are static concept they don't embody any
motion there is no motion involved in
there no action
let's go now to another we're going to
teach the Klingon another word now here
okay let's find out
this is the word ah when
to the other side give me a second here
let me get it back
you gotta teach them the word ion
can you put the word ion in a single
frame of the movie of The Universal
movie
and he answers no you point and you say
well that's a ball with a plus sign out
over it
what does it stand for I mean there's
two objects there there's a plus sign
and a ball
and you have to explain to him that well
something's happening okay what is it
that's happening well in order to change
to explain happening Behavior you know
action you need two frames of the film
you need motion okay and that's what you
got to show you got to say look what
happened is the atom lost a marble lost
an electron lost a ball
so but for that lost you know got rid of
you know is is a verb is an action
there's something going on you need two
frames of the film of the universal film
you got to show first one frame where
the
ball is there and the other one where
the ball is no longer there that's an
ion and ion means something happened to
the atom iron is not a standalone object
iron is something happened to this atom
that's what the word ion means and
that's what the word plasma means you
can't point to plasma because plasma is
ionization ionization you need two
frames of the film because you got to
explain to the Klingon in this case that
the atom lost an electron
for that you need two frames of the film
that's what plasma requires that's what
plasma is you can't point to plasma
because plasma is a verb it's an action
it's a process just like fire the word
plasma embodies motion the word Stone
the word table the word uh ceiling wall
Rock tree none of those embody Motion in
the word itself the word plasma does the
word fire does the word wind does all
these words embody motion you cannot
have wind in one frame of the movie
if you have wind in one frame of the
movie you have air so far you have air
so far you don't have wind or hurricane
or tornado or vortex
okay we got that this is uh kindergarten
stuff okay so if you haven't if you
don't understand that you you flunk
kindergartens okay kindergarten physics
okay windfall suggests uh that uh you
know you can pull uh with a corkscrew
mechanism he says what can you throw at
something that will Attract it notice
that he says throw okay he says what can
you throw at something that will Attract
it he says a corkscrew Cyclone okay
because he's saying that action at a
distance you can throw like a stone at
something and Attract it okay that was
the issue he's trying to explain Gravity
by throwing something one way and he's
going to say you can do it with
something like a course grew which is
more or less like water running down a
drain says radiation moves in outward
spirals radiation radiation moves
radiation is a concept there's no
physical object called radiation but he
doesn't understand that because he
hasn't gone through kindergarten physics
gravity is a reciprocal Force just like
water spiraling down a drain while it
airs simultaneously pulled upward out of
the drain all motion is two ways
okay so the issue here is that water
rushing down a drain water is made out
of molecules they're going one way okay
and it's uh you would have to have
infinite water for that to happen Okay
for it to go Always Forever in one way
okay uh but that's not the same thing as
the corkscrew that you see on the left
the one on the bottom left uh you can
say that that's already connecting two
ends source and Target okay that's
different than something being thrown at
something else so when he says when you
throw something he's talking about the
water going through the through the
drain he's not referring to the
corkscrew but for him he sees nothing
different between the corkscrew and
water rushing down the drain these are
not the same scenarios because if you're
going to use the corkscrew then you're
talking about something like the Rope
where something is already connecting
physically one object to the other okay
that's different and you can't use words
such as radiation or spiral or Vortex or
anything like that because those are not
physical objects you got to tell me what
physical object is torquing in this case
I'm showing a corkscrew you know the
mechanism there it's a mediator no
problem but then you have to show that
and say what is that thing that you're
pointing to there you can now talk about
water rushing down a drain and say
that's the same thing as a corkscrew but
this well doesn't understand these basic
things they're so smart they're so
arrogant you know they know everything
so they don't even understand these
basic things
okay one fellow says why can't I use
black magic as my mechanism
okay why can't he I mean I mean can't we
explain with black magic isn't that a
mechanism the answer is no black magic
no mechanism at all
because black magic you cannot see the
mechanism
You're just showing what I show there a
spoon over here and it falling to the
floor and you cannot tell me what caused
that spoon to fall to the floor you know
you see the spoon see if I can do this
okay you let go of it and it falls to
the floor
so it falls and you can't see the
mechanism and so black magic is no
mechanism at all make a movie of your
mechanism
and then we'll know whether Blackmagic
can pass the test okay
okay and finally we have a fella who
also flat earther who brings it into the
topic of Extinction which we're very
close to I mean here we have the war in
Ukraine and all this stuff right uh
inflation uh there's going to be more
Unemployment uh the interest rates are
going to rise I guess uh who knows we're
going to have a great couple of next
years okay but here this fellow says the
following says you guaranteed a bold
prediction that we are the last
generation of humans uh no I made no
prediction okay and again this fella was
educated by The Establishment he talks
about prediction he uses these words
such as prediction and so he doesn't
understand the difference between a
prediction and an explanation that's
where the problem starts despite the
best mathematical Concepts not even
economists can make reliable predictions
in either the short or long term yeah
we're not talking about predictions at
all and he doesn't understand that a
mass extinction event involving a
collapse of the food chain triggered by
the value of money going to zero yeah
there we go no farming because no money
Global starvation inevitable you do know
money is No Object uh yeah no kidding
money is a mathematical concept hey he's
a smart fellow okay economics doesn't
deal in explanations economics is not
science
poor fellow again it's because he
doesn't Define his terms so he thinks
all of this is a prediction and all I
can recommend to anyone who uses the
word prediction uh here it is synthesis
you have to do Extinction 101 before you
do Extinction 102.
first you got to tell me past
extinctions explain past extinctions
give me the mechanism of how species in
the past which are already in the ground
or bones are in the ground their fossils
are there you got to tell me how those
became extinct first okay once you have
a mechanism a physical mechanism once
you can explain
animals plants and animals Etc in the
air and land and sea disappeared
okay once you have that that's extension
101 now you can tell me now you're an
expert to tell me something about human
extinction
and no it's not a prediction it's called
an explanation we're explaining the
mechanism of how humans are going to
disappear we're not making a prediction
a prediction is on the first of May of
the Year 2030 the last human is going to
die that's a prediction we don't do that
here we can't tell you when
a the last human's going to die oh we
can tell it which is extinction of the
human race right now we can tell you the
mechanism what is going to cause the
extinction of man because Mother Nature
uses the same cookie cutter on all
species
and to use this mechanism on all species
in the past once you get the cookie
cutter once you know the mechanism you
apply it to man and see if man can avoid
that same mechanism and it turns out
it's economics science yes and so there
first you got to take Extinction 101
before 102. it's not a prediction it's
an explanation okay and mechanism of
mechanism of mass extinction is
economics
that's why economics is an explanation
all animals have economics economics is
the management of resources all animals
manage resources they manage one
resource specifically it's called food
all animals manage food and that's known
as economics and when food runs out uh
the animals run out that's more or less
in a nutshell a mass extinction and the
same thing will happen to man man will
disappear in the mass extinction not in
a background Extinction where the last
of a dynasty of hominids
monkeys whatever you want to call this
mass extinction disappearance of an
entire food chain that's what a mass
extinction is and we're due for
extinction very soon but hey you gotta
explain them Extinction of uh the
animals in the past then you can talk
about the extinction of man but these
people skip that step because they know
nothing absolutely nothing about
paleontology they know nothing about uh
how animals disappear they don't have an
idea they just borrow from The
Establishment and they say oh I think
the dinosaurs died when the comet hit
the earth and that's all they know
they don't even know the animals of the
Permian are the Triassic or whatever
they have no idea whatsoever and they
say oh but I'm an expert in uh human
extinction I know humans will never die
or if they die they'll die because of
what climate change disease uh
uh what is it um
what other ones peak oil you know they
have all these maybe a comet will hit
the Earth
okay so they know nothing about
Extinction but they're experts
okay we had our science critic
let's get to them our science critic and
what did he say well he had uh something
to say about the scientific method and
he says that something
um in the scientific method the
important part of the scientific method
is what we what they call falsification
which came from Mr Carl popper a
supposedly philosopher of physics
whatever that is philosopher of science
Okay let's listen to him this is what
he's got to say about science and
whether falsification plays any role
whatsoever in it here he goes give me a
second okay
here it goes listen carefully
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal include
can an equation explain what caused a
phenomena
and this proper falsification have
anything to do with science
an equation can tell you why things
happen if you want to know why things
break when they fall from a 10-story
building an equation can help you with
that and the thing is equations allow
for specificity if you do not have any
specificity it makes it very difficult
to test your ideas so you pretty much
need equations to be able to test ideas
and if you can't test ideas then that
makes that idea unfalsifiable and as
we've discussed unfalsifiable ideas are
irrational
of course if he doesn't Define what
irrational means it just says uh
anything that's unfalsifiable is
irrational you know that's that's
absolute nonsense has no validity he
hasn't defined uh what irrationality is
but we're going to skip that for today
we're just going to get to the following
here you have an equation Force equals
mass times acceleration okay does that
tell you why the box came up in the uh
case of the pulley does it tell you how
the window broke
if you just say Force mass times
acceleration you know someone gives you
that equation says force times Force
equals mass times acceleration
what have they explained with that
equation okay and there you have the
spoon falling to the floor
you know again a force a mysterious
Force
you still don't know the mechanism so no
uh mathematics can only describe and a
description is not a mechanism it
doesn't give you any idea what caused
something to happen
and uh as far as falsification you know
I mean we don't falsify anything in
science but here's Mr Popper's uh
synthesis okay this is uh What uh popper
believed in this is what he proposed for
science okay and papa says uh he
believed that scientific knowledge is
provisional that it's an ongoing process
again that's what people just memorize
and just repeat they say it's in uh uh
you know an ongoing process the best we
can do at the moment and so they never
answer the questions because they say
well we still don't know we're still
investigating and science is just in a a
process of Investigation that's all it
is and all they do is just measure get
equations they say they have ever more
accurate equations and they have no
explanation no rational explanations
whatsoever and they always explain with
the motion of Concepts that's why
they're irrational and it says popper is
known for his attempt to refute the
classical positive this account of the
scientific method by replacing induction
with a falsification principle okay what
is the falsification principle was
proposed by Carl popper is a way of
demarcating science from non-science
okay so the guy who doesn't do
falsifications on nine scientists okay
it suggests that for a theory to be
considered scientific it must be able to
be tested and conceivably proven false
proven false to whom
to the Pope I mean these people are
talking about belief they're not talking
about science so Papa had no idea
whatsoever okay he thought that science
had something to do with belief with
proving with convincing people and so
he's saying it's got to be tested okay
test it for what so that I can convince
you that my theory is correct meaning
believe meaning I'm going to twist your
arm
it's got nothing to do with science got
to do with belief and belief is religion
not science so what Carl popper defined
was the religion not science for example
the hypothesis that all swans are white
can be falsified by observing a Black
Swan okay uh yeah it's a hypothesis
because you're making an assumption but
these people are talking about theories
and they call that a hypothesis for
popper science should uh should attempt
to disprove a theory rather than attempt
to continually support theoretical
hypothesis okay and again what popper
talked about is not science he talked
about religion religion is about belief
about proving about testing
testing for what for verification
verification for what to convince
convince for what to prove to persuade
to convince convert recruit
it has to do with belief so what
property fine has nothing to do at all
with science and yet descriptions are
not science explanations are science it
doesn't take any
mental capacity any mental effort any
energy you know to describe something so
so so you know the pencil fell to the
floor you know great and
uh I do the experiment I describe it I
can tell you how fast it wouldn't what
the acceleration is I still don't know
why I have no cause no mechanism
that's where you have to break your
brain that's where you have to try to
visualize the invisible world of Mother
Nature
with that I'll see you next week next
Sunday we'll see you